cuando llegas a matemáticas a un nivel
superior tal vez te encuentres con esta
anotación una erre con doble línea atrás
y lo que parece ser un exponente 2 o en
los libros de texto te vas a encontrar
con una erre en letra negrita y con el 2
arriba ahora que es esto
esto simplemente es la notación la
anotación para para el espacio de dos
dimensiones con coordenadas reales
aparece algo elegante se escucha algo
elegante pero no simplemente de hecho es
el espacio en el cual tú ya estás
acostumbrado a trabajar es este espacio
de dos dimensiones de hecho para entrar
algo un poco un poco más abstracto y
esto no representa realmente a r2 solo
es una manera de pensar en esto porque
bueno si lo si lo pensamos un poco más
abstracto r2 es el espacio con
coordenadas reales de dos dimensiones
luego lo escribo entonces este es el
espacio de dos dimensiones
r2 es de dos dimensiones donde el dos
nos nos dice en cuantas dimensiones
estamos trabajando y la erre nos dice
que es un espacio con coordenadas
reales eso es r 2 así que es por
excelencia el espacio de dos dimensiones
con coordenadas reales entonces en
resumen son todas las combinaciones
posibles de coordenadas reales con dos
entradas lo voy a escribir entonces
todas las posibles dos duplas con
valores reales donde una dupla es una
lista ordenada de números y como estamos
trabajando con números reales será una
lista ordenada de números reales ahora
el 2 en 2 tu plan nos indica que estamos
trabajando con una lista ordenada de dos
números y es exactamente lo mismo que
hicimos aquí cuando estábamos hablando
sobre sobre vectores de dos dimensiones
ajá este este es un vector o es una dos
duplas con valores reales el 3 y el 4
son números reales no hay ninguna parte
imaginaria ahí tienes el 3 y tienes el 4
donde el orden importa porque esto no es
lo mismo estados tu plan es diferente a
digamos a todos tu plan 4 3 están
estados tu plan queda
más o menos por aquí si la tabula mos
entonces cuatro espacios en el eje
horizontal y después tres en el eje
vertical ahí quedaría el 43 y recuerda
que un vector tiene dirección y magnitud
entonces bueno este vector no tiene o no
necesariamente debe salir del origen
puede ser así así que este vector
también sería el vector 4 3 el vector
columna 4 3 así que cuando hablamos
sobre r 2 o acerca de r 2 estamos
hablando sobre todas las combinaciones
posibles de dos duplas con valores
reales entonces todas las posibles
combinaciones en vectores donde cada
componente éstos son los componentes de
los números y son reales puede pues por
ejemplo tener a 34 menos 3 menos 4 donde
quedaría el menos 3 menos 4 o algo así
no de hecho voy a voy a ponerlo un poco
más a escala
quedaría más o menos por aquí el menos 3
menos 4 éste es el vector menos 3 lo
escribo mejor
- 3 - 4 ahí está así que si tomas todas
las posibles dos duplas con valores
reales incluyendo de hecho al 0 0 es el
vector que no tiene magnitud y puedes
debatir en cuál es su dirección pero no
tiene mucho caso entonces si tomas las
combinaciones de todas esas dos tu plan
estará tendrás el espacio de dos
dimensiones
r2 y puedes imaginar tal vez porque puse
ese 2 ahí lo podemos cambiar si quieres
de hecho puedo poner qué pasa si ponemos
r3 puede ser cualquier número pero r 3
quienes r 3 es el espacio de tres
dimensiones con coordenadas reales
espacio de tres dimensiones con
coordenadas reales son todas las
posibles tres duplas con valores reales
por ejemplo a ok este sería un elemento
de r3 digamos que tenemos el vector
000 este pertenece a r3 ajam luego ya lo
voy a nombrar x si tenemos un vector
digamos b entonces ves el vector menos 1
5 y 3 ambos son elementos de r 3 no es
increíble está genial si quieres por
ejemplo ver notación elegante aquí está
te presento x pertenece a r3 ese símbolo
es pertenece es miembro de r3 ajá
que no sería un miembro de r3 por
ejemplo este no sería un miembro de r3
éste pertenece a r2 pero no a r3 no es
una no es una 3 tú pla es una 2 tu plan
así que pertenece a r2 ahora un ejemplo
de un vector que no pertenezca a r3
sería por ejemplo este con entradas
imaginarias digamos y 0 y 1 este ya no
tiene valores reales ajá aquí aquí tiene
una parte imaginaria por lo tanto este
ya está ya ya no es una 3 to pla con
valores reales ya no pertenece a r3 y lo
genial de álgebra lineal o lo mágico
aquí es que tenemos tenemos aquí a r3 y
lo podemos visualizar pero podríamos
trabajar con más dimensiones por ejemplo
qué te parece cuatro dimensiones cinco
dimensiones diez dimensiones 20 100 mil
dimensiones aunque claro ya sería un
poco difícil si no imposible
visualizarlo aunque yo no me preocuparía
si fuera tú porque podemos representarlo
matemáticamente ok esto una n dupla una
n tu plan donde n es cualquier número 20
100 mil lo que sea sería por ejemplo rn
rn es el espacio de n dimensiones
de mi dimensiones con coordenadas reales
entonces es el espacio n dimensional de
coordenadas reales